[音楽]
こんにちは川上洋平です今日は俺は誰
ん
僕たちはそう大学工学部で大百科に所属しています
今日は皆さんに僕たちが以前行った課題について
僕たちが気づいたことをお話ししようと思います
今年の4月僕たちは授業で人と人と前
インターアクションを応じて一定まで課題を行いました
インタラクションとは相互作用です
これは辞書的な意味ですが今回の課題は人と人と間にいたらくしょんを作る
つまり人と人との間に関係を作る仕組みを考えるというものでした
そこで僕たちは
人の動きに反応して花火をプロジェクションを
東映性という企画を行いました
なぜ金具にしたかというとこれは僕のあるとしていたらあっています
音楽ライブのスタッフのアルバイトをしていたらいい
スタジアムのととのバス停に客様を案内する仕事を決めました
終焉間近ん常にバス停は混み合っていました
その時スタジオの中からトンブ花火が母だったんです
それとバス停に沿いのお客様みんなが足を止めて振り返って花火が増えたんです
そして口々にすごい写真すごいなって
写真を撮っていました
合わせ方を見て僕は花火みんなを交わしを楽しませることができるんだなと感じました
そこで考えた一つ目のアイディアがこちらです
これは目を打ってあのお話しします
まず最高空いてると
横目に入らせます何だろうと思ってご理解いただけると実はそこにスクリーンに投影さ
れた花ブラウンですてるんです
1回足を止めてみると範囲だと思うんでしたーい
またなんだろうと思いダイキャスト離れられます
これはもしかして自分の動きに反応して花火やスクリーンに映ってるんじゃないかと
思っ
彼はそこについています
こんな感じで行
こういう人の姿を見たらどうしても気になってしまいます
ここで年間いただくとか思うんじゃないかというのが2つめの会いたいです
実際に本当にこれが起こるのかというのを検証していました
音には改善用事がありました
もう一つ分かったことは暗いところであれば特にでも映像を投影できるのではないかと
いうことです
そこで次に考えたアイデアがこちらです
一気に話を移していたら綺麗なじゃないかと考えました
ん
先ほどは手動で打ち上げみましたが今回は自動化することを考えて
機能を考えました
仕組みはコチラです
まず戦災を務め浮き上がり申します
そこデータ信号をパソコンがプログラムで花火を描きます
エアからな話はプロジェクターを通って映像
スピーカーを通って乙女座されます
その仕組みを実際に製作する作業に入りました
防衛する雪に足を運んで取材を調整したい
手を動かしてプログラムを組み立てたりします
そしてこのイメージをもとに試していました
うん
日
ああああああ
そう上手くは行かせました
そこでもだったらは水面には良させないということでした
かろうじてひまわりのすっぴんの通りたちでした
そしてこれを基にし第3段目のアイディアを考えました
実際に移してみましたご覧くださいフ
ありません
最後に熱していると色見られて結構きれいなんですけれどもこれはかなりだということ
が全くわかりませんでした
ただ肌のように見上げるというかまぁ
とても人の感情的になっていることにシャツ
そして次のトライアルを行いました
記事は頭のな壁面に水してました
[音楽]
今までのトライアルよりもはっきりと映像が映ることが分かりました
またしてもの1みんなで大きく公演することができるのではないかと思いました
このトライアルを経て5月21日30日に僕たちは大学構内でこの企画を行いました
実際にいろいろな方々がこの200に興味を示してくれました
ご覧ください
あっはぁ
ます
ん
ああああああ
[音楽]
ん
ああああああ
[拍手]
新たなんだ
とても興味を持っていただいてすごく嬉しかったです
実際に戦車の大転倒みなさんこれは何だろうと思って近づいてくれますそこで地下する
とセンサーが反応した花びらじゃああることに気づくと面白いと言ってセンサーの前で
植えてみたい
写真を撮ってみたい
とてもに印象強かったらば先ほどすごいでしょうと言った
ぽちゃっです彼女は近くの軽食屋さんのおばちゃんなんですけれども
彼女が通ったときにそこに彼はタバコおりがかった女子大生中って
月なよ面白いよって一緒に2人が遊んなんですね
おばあちゃんの統治体制がそそんなことは僕は全く思ってもいなかったのでものすごい
いただくさんが打ったらと感じました
def
うちの子の客を磨いています
当初の目標は一つ一との間でいた落車大雄
でした
この動きを発生するためにまず
できるところから始めました
まず最初
手動で絵像投影し口年花火の増トン
いうようなものでした
そして試して失敗してを展開して別に
だんだんとまわりの人と関わる機会もできインタラクション
近づいていますか
その枚熱と変わっていく過程もとても授業でした
プログラミングがわからないときは先輩直接気に入った
電源を引くためのコードを一つとっても自分たちゃん持っていないのでいろいろな方々
から延長コードを書いてつなぎ合わせたいとかそういったことも思いました
そしてこの人と人との間にインタラクションをつけるという課題を終えることができ
ました
そこで
その課題は終わったんですが
僕たちはそれを割高思いませんでした
今回の資格ではこの空白にはクロちゃんと染色のおばあちゃんフローチャート仲良く
なったことそれとこの添付の場に出させていただいていることが入るんだと思います
会社に思いついたことをまず作ってみる
それを北に見せている
そうすることで最初の思いつきがどんどん楽しいものに変わっていくんだなと
2つだと思いました
当初の目標であった
インタラクションを作るということは完成したんですがその後にたくさんの
インタラクションと思いました
課題としては完了したんですが課題以上のものがどんどん分いただくさんとして広がっ
ていることに気が付きました
最悪段階までたちは課題を倒して気がついたことです
最後にん
才能ん
皆さんでこれインタラクションを押そうと思います
今日は昨秋を半拍手に反応してスクリーン
花火が乗ってるん
そういったものをつけてきました
スクリーンを花火いっぱいにしてください
me
早く連敗にしてくれると嬉しいんでこう拍手の授業
もうちょっともうちょっとでが最高拍手の寿命
待っててください
クロちゃんとはですねあの
あん定食屋のおばちゃんとわー
越冬2わー
歳といったのはもない初めてだったんですけどその時に
ねぎまをごちそうしてもらっ
なかなかそんなことない方について僕たちのことをしっかり覚えててくれたんです
そいでその半年も経ってても僕たちのことを覚えてくれるというのはとてもすごいこと
だと思います
これはいくじゃないですか
mar
4の
約6か月にクロちゃん者は変わったんですけどまだ名前を持ってくれっ
目があるからカー結果わかる戦で直にカットしている
彼はいらっしゃいません
あれ
[拍手]